never doubt the prague was one of the  words used in the studio here earlier  you find a way to uncomplicate here at  the end and find the draw  um yeah i don't know probably i was  worse in the middle game i was trying to  find some tactical blue but  yeah i i couldn't find it i  like none of them were working  and uh somehow i managed to uh liquidate  to a drawing  outside of uh this you've been outside  of these tournaments in the champions  chester you have to play a lot of open  tournaments do you notice the difference  in level strongly when you play  yeah i think there is huge difference i  mean  all these players are very strong and  it's not  easy to  win games against this place you make it  look easier brian  not really it's quite bad  good luck thanks